yannick nézet-séguin a toutes les
raisons de se réjouir l'année 2018 de
son orchestre métropolitain a été
exceptionnel c'est clair que c'est notre
année la plus spéciale la plus
merveilleuse depuis toute l'existence de
leurs questions
[Musique]
fort du succès de la tournée européenne
de l'automne 2017 leur qu'istres en a
reçu les retombées en 2018
il a obtenu six prix dont celui de la
meilleure tournée internationale du
conseil des arts et des lettres du
québec
il y a aussi eu des enregistrements pour
la prestigieuse compagnie de disques 2
grammophon c'est sûr qu'un autre
grammophon pour moi que quand j'étais
jeune adolescente j'achetais d'un disque
de dire à mes fans jamais j'avais pensé
qu'un jour mon enquête de montréal lors
que ce métropolitain à l'aide sur deux
journaux folle
il ya aussi la vente des abonnements de
saison alors qu'istres métropolitaine
qui a connu une année record avec une
augmentation de 17 % passant de près de
1300 abonnement en 2017 2018 à plus de
1500 c'est une conjoncture c'est que
c'est vraiment un ensemble de choses qui
se mettent en place
puis on dirait qu'à partir du moment où
tout se met en place c'est que le simple
ce cas tourner dans le bon sens tout
cela dans la foulée de l'arrivée de
yannick nézet séguin à la direction
musicale du metropolitan opera de new
york
tout ce qui m'a empli c'est la gratitude
d'abord c'est un rêve un rêve éveillé
les prix disque la reconnaissance
l'orchestré métropolitain attribue son
succès en bonne partie au génie de
yannick nézet séguin
je veux par le dialecte parce que c'est
lui qui nous ouvre ses portes la nuit
nous a permis de se développer a
longtemps dans nos talents et de
comprendre aussi qu'on n'était pas lui
ce que je te donne c'est un infime
partie de l'impact
yannick
l'impact du maestro pourraient se faire
sentir encore longtemps à l'orchestré
métropolitain
car il n'est pas question pour lui de
joindre les rangs de l'orchestré
symphonique de montréal
j'adore mon orchestre puis je respecte
beaucoup évidemment le casting de
montréal mais moi ma place c'est à l'om
c'est tout
je pense que ce qu'on a développée sont
certainement spécial que je vois pas
qu'est ce qui pourrait se passer
qu'ils fassent qu'on veuille se séparer
lors qu'est ce que son chef ont
plusieurs projets pour 2019 et pour
l'instant rien ne semble vouloir les
arrêter ici wifi depuis mai radio-canada
moria